these miners have held out underground
in deplorable conditions for nearly four
weeks now they're exhausted and
desperate some have even been taken to
the hospital but the others are staying
put and fighting to save their gold mine
and some 2,000 jobs their fury is aimed
at the left-wing syriza government
what's going on here is an absolute
scandal
who does this tsipras think he is he
wants private investment to get us out
of a crisis but at the same time he's
throwing investors out nobody will want
to invest in this country under these
conditions what can we do emigrate we're
completely alone in this fight no
political party is supporting us the
license for the gold mine on the high
KDK Peninsula was held by a Canadian
consortium but the syriza government
revoked it saying the threat to the
environment was incalculable a
particular bone of contention is the
plans by the mine operator Hellas gold
to set up a huge dump for sand tailings
washed out with cyanide local
communities are locked in a bitter
dispute the - relatives are posted along
the access roads trying to convince
anyone who'll listen that environmental
concerns are only a pretext
and I'm talking to those people to wake
up because they heard a lot of lies and
everything from a person persons for
their reasons up to 250 tons of gold are
estimated in the ground here about 9
billion euros worth that Greece and it's
cash-strapped condition could well use
as the miners point out they're hoping
for a change of governments opponents of
the mines say that's just propaganda
among them hotel owner Christos Artemis
this territory here has earthquakes we
want to make a dam of 150 meters high
and here behind - 150 million tons of
toxic waste forever and all this is
crazy
opponents of the mine gets support from
environmental and anti-globalization
forces throughout Greece the conflict
has even turned violent on occasion the
mayor of the nearby village of scurries
himself a syriza supporter is confident
the mind will never resume operations he
condemns the violence but says the
investors are ultimately to blame
unfortunately the owners are
manipulating the workers to serve their
own interests I've invited the unions
for a dialogue but it must be clear that
has the town council we not only have to
promote jobs but also protect the
citizens health
engineers from Hellas gold have been
lobbying political parties with plans
for an environmentally sound waste
disposal system and promises to restore
the natural vegetation if the mind gets
its license back that's what the miners
are demanding their livelihoods are at
stake
this dispute I haven't earned anything
for weeks now and I had to move my
family to another village because almost
all our neighbors are against the mind
my kids have even been bullied at school
yes papa rotten mother nabarro Paulo the
mine is want to go back to work
and they're hoping this Sunday's
election will set something in motion
but many have lost hope for the mine and
for the future of Greece no matter who
wins the next election